for those of you who weren't present
last week what I went over was
middlegame positions from the Olympia
I'm going to continue to do this you
know I'm just going to use a few
different examples so today one of the
focuses I wanted to talk about was
planning now how do you think planning
is important in the middle game it's
important another phases too but in the
middle game in particular basically
you're kind of reacting to your opponent
you're playing when you play move to
move and a lot of positions you should
play move to move it's a way you know in
a lot of positions you have to react to
what your opponents do it you have no
choice or you have to deal with
immediate threats but let's say if you
don't have any of that okay your
opponent might not kill you or whatever
there's no killing here but if your
opponent has a clear plan and you don't
what often happens is that you know
their moves all have a sim have a
purpose like they may play one move
which deals with a threat but they have
a long-term goal they have a plan so I
chose this example this was a game
between this is actually in the final
match between Russia and Canada and
before you for those of you don't know
we're going why was Canada in the final
well Canada was quite a few points it
was like a point and a half back of us
or something like this but we still had
to beat them to win the tournament was
the deal and this game actually went
against us so in this game Eric Hanson
was white a Canadian GM who you guys
might know he actually spent some time
in st. Louis and he's waiting in Sam's
England who's who was our board form
and actually used to be a student of
mine briefly before he turned to the
dark side so just he was actually a
student mine for a very people anyways
now he can teach me okay but in any case
so uh do do so this position by the way
blacks position is totally fine here
completely fine oh yeah however this was
the key in this position what separated
the two players was that white was
slightly better prepared for this game I
would say but what was bigger more
important is that white hasn't had a
clear plan and actually accomplished it
all game now a lot of the times you have
a plan but you have to constantly adapt
your opponent throws something at you
you don't expect or they're trying to
prevent your plan you have to adapt you
can't just stay glued to one plan it's
very rare but it's nice to have a
long-term plan even if you're dealing
with threats or doing other things
because then it makes it so that when
there isn't a moment where you have to
do with an immediate threat you know
exactly what your goal is so in this
case white had a plan and black did not
and that's separated to do players and
you'll see how it actually just decided
the game the fact that white had a plan
in this middle game and black did not so
first off it's black to me so the
question is what's going on here what
needs to be done
right White's King is definitely more
open than it would like to be if the
King weren't open I would say that white
would have a totally I would just be up
a palm probably so yeah black has the
bishop which targets f2 could possibly
be good but why definitely is upon's is
a good and it's not exactly clear what
blacks compensation is would you say
that black has long-term compensation or
does black need to prove something
immediately or would you say it's a
combination of both but I would agree so
now the question becomes what do you
want to accomplish what it should your
main goal here be there's one more thing
in the position you need to identify
what are some questions you can ask
yourself in any position yeah what's the
worst piece I have absolutely here I
don't think Black has any pieces that
are too bad so that's probably not the
question here but it's a great question
what other questions and by the way
asking yourself questions during the
game is a great thing to do I try to get
all my students and I try to get myself
to do it it's not always easy
weaknesses
there's either side have a weakness one
of the great things about blacks
position is that there are no weaknesses
right how about I don't think Y can say
the same yep
that would be my choice too now that
pawn is defended well enough but okay
the right now the queen is pinned and
it's not entirely clear
you know how lights gonna further to you
know defend that pawn even better so so
if you can target that pawn I think that
that's going to be pretty good for you
it's a good question there's Queen c4
check exactly and then you're gonna be
sorry you played SS keep in mind that I
move like f6 weakens your leg scores
horrible so you have to be absolutely
certain you're there's no danger or that
black doesn't have anything great they
can do up to f6 otherwise you're gonna
be really sorry you played that so what
else
in the game black played rook d7 which
by itself is not a horrible move but it
also does not really you know it's
limited to what it improves because if
rook de7 the knight goes back to d3
there's no huge problem and it just
didn't accomplish quite enough so black
needed to target the e pawn in a more
efficient manner
so what piece needs to be involved to
target that eat long very nice
so Queen e7 I think whoa I love the big
big language here so preparing Bishop c7
was black was best because now the
problem with Bishop c7 is if the knight
was back g3 then you can think about f6
but you have moves like c5 or you could
just try to target the knight you're
Queen h4 it you just have all these
possibilities and it's not entirely
clear how White's going to defend
everything so is the game over is white
not have anything I don't know but this
because it threatens to come out to the
Kings side in some cases because of the
ends Bishop c7 you have clear ideas I
think this was the best option and
you'll see how quickly blacks position
deteriorated here
he played rook d7 so now the key is to
figure out what white does so white has
for the key for white is that you want
to have a clear plan but also achieve
this plan with as little counter play as
possible so what should White's plan
here be
excellent that's the question
white what white needs is to somehow
solidify any pipeline if white gets that
pond solid blacks just going to be
suffering and eventually black white
will play e6 probably we can the lag
squares I mean I'm not a fortune-teller
but those are the types of ideas that
white should look for but the key is
first you have to solidify the e5 one
so first so before you do anything come
up with a possible plan to solidify that
guy so the best so kimchi to is actually
an excellent move I think but it has a
very clear purpose to it and the key is
to figure out why King g2 is a nice move
there's a positional point and a
tactical point
the positional points easier so let's
start with that yeah right well that's I
could say more the tactical point it
gets out of the pin but also it you know
besides getting out of the pin it holds
on to h3 it guards the squares and Queen
f3 looks a little nicer it's just it's
one of those moves that I call it almost
a housekeeping which is means that it
just it makes your position a little
better it's not anything drastic but it
just makes your position a little better
all around it to guard this it guards
this and I'd say that G if you notice in
G M games GM's play a lot of
housekeeping moves we like our positions
nice and neat we don't like pawns
hanging places we don't like you know
stuff being loose we want everything
nice and guarded usually so it's a nice
habit to get into if you can't do
anything better to find a housekeeping
move obviously you look at temple moves
and you know moves that are more
aggressive first but if they don't work
out a housekeeping move can be nice but
it's also important that the F pawn gets
out of the pin for example well well
actually we'll come back to this moment
so King G 2 is played and now black
played King h8 so yeah I mean black
maybe should try rook d7 but white can
simply play back and if C 5 C 4 and this
Knights pretty solid and notice how
there's nothing on the D file now so
there's not so easy to target this
Knight so y can play the Queen e4 rookie
three rook D you on and okay I mean
White's improved not to mention this
Bishop seems kind of embarrassed okay so
in the game black played King h8 to kind
of get out of light square stuff again
not so sure it's the best move but
blacks kind of play move to move just
dealing with problems as they come which
is not always bad but I'd say in this
case he really ended up just kind of
without a plan and white and really had
a plan so this is actually one of the
really cool moves of the game it's not
the first move that would come to mind
at least not for me but it's a really
really nice move which you know kind of
goes with White's plan of solidify e5 so
in order to come by this move let's take
it step by step
first you have to figure out what is the
ideal setup to defend this epoch what
would be the dream yes I would say
that's a possible dream but it wouldn't
be my dream and the reason why is
because with the pawn enough for your
king is more open and I would also say
that you're maybe more vulnerable to f6
type moves in some situations your
knight has to find a square I would not
say that's the dream that's kind of like
okay maybe you know if you have to do it
it's not bad but it wouldn't be my first
choice
yeah The Epoch F for the F pawn that
would be okay but I don't think it's
quite possible yet I
I mean after ecig screen takes Knight is
always a worry you have to worry about
doubling rooks and trying to take that
pawn I'd say that II six you're not
ready for it yet what would be the dream
it's just for defending that pot right
now you have Queen only two rook anyone
what would you much prefer but you don't
want your net on d3 right yeah and also
it's just I mean it would be nicer if
you could do it without the night there
but an hour d3 is a more passive Knight
you put it there if you have to but if
you not forced to do it you'd rather not
so what else is idea right now there's a
queen only two rook anyone what's the
problem with this setup which piece of
yours is odd it doesn't look right
it's okay what piece is out of play in
the Queenie - rookie one set up which of
these pieces is not quite ready well the
rook on a1 is definitely not
participating which we'll get to we just
put it on g2 the Queen anyone will be
okay but mostly I'd rather have the
rooks doubled if you could get Queen f3
rookie 2 rookies won that to me as I do
because then you're ready to play six it
probably can't be stopped and your rooks
are going to be on the open file your
queen goes to a better square you're not
pin to me that's the dream and sometimes
you you just you can't live your dream
it's just one of those things but in
this case why got to live the dream the
question is how did he achieve it
because if Queen f3 here there was a
concrete problem
rook takes e5 right so how did he get
this dream
what what was the move you wanted to
play Queenie for right but you can't
play it because of rook D to fix that
problem
if Brooke do you want to trade and take
so
running out of options
so you guys are trying to be efficient
with your time and really do it quickly
normally that's a great thing you don't
want to give your opponent tons of time
the problem here for black is that black
has almost nothing to do black has no
threats and no way to repair the
position which means well what's your
idea with a 4 ok so if I put my pawn on
a 6 and not let you try my Bishop okay
he did something similar and I'm using
the word similar kind of generously yeah
ah Queen c2 I can still take on e5 right
Queen takes
I can take that room as a nice try
though I like your spirit of back rank
trickery but yeah it's an excellent idea
it says so right you didn't realize this
is faster right
okay so rook c1 to c2 now here's what I
wanted to point out to you why oh why
did he not play this move immediately
and this is where housekeeping moves
come in handy because it looks like this
should be totally possible now right
believe it or not black has an idea and
it uses the fact that the king is on g1
well ff6 immediately have quincy for
check again but you have the right idea
so now I'm forced to play Knight d3 and
now and now there are two problems first
of all this pawn if this pawn moves
there's an unpleasant surprise waiting
between G for your check and it f4 then
Bishop takes King is there an even more
unpleasant surprise so um yeah so you
out and so now all of a sudden I okay
it's not like White has no chances here
or anything like that I mean probably
Queen e4 black takes but at least now
Black Swan the pawn back so black has
some chances
not to mention that f2 can still be weak
like I think that the knight looks
better than the bishop but maybe maybe
black can do okay there um which is why
he played King g2 first so you see how I
won't like kimchi too looks like a
simple improving move that's how it
looked to my eyes at first but it
actually had a very concrete purpose and
believe me he knew that this was his
plan so King h8 rook c1 so black plays
a6 we can say if we assume this move
does not contain a threat so what's our
plan right and these are the types of
moves which you want to be careful to
make sure f6 doesn't contain some hidden
thing like oh bishop a7 Queen b6 with
mate but obviously not but when your
opponent doesn't really place a move
like a six it means that you can play a
quicker move rook c1 you probably want
to spend some time but once you do that
the nice thing while having a plan is
you can actually play quicker so I'm
sure he played rook c2 pretty quickly so
black played Queen d8 black decided okay
I have to do something about this plan
because otherwise it's gonna kill me so
Quincy for looks like an okay
it means you have the wrong answer
Quincy for Quincy for looks looks
reasonable to me I don't see anything
wrong with it I obviously didn't play
that um but let's see so rook t2 seems
logical although I think it might just
lose after takes and I don't know
there's f2 hanging still but okay let's
check it out so takes takes Queen takes
but you can probably just play here
right Queen has to move back and then
he's six now this looks so great for you
right g6 comes so maybe there's
something else but I'm not really sure
cuz rookie 7 e6 looks really nasty that
looks not a lot like not a lot of fun I
don't know to me this looks like a fine
choice he played Queen f3 which is
similar I would say right but his idea
is he wants to double rooks and get the
ideal position right so black plays
Bishop c7 he finally figured out he had
to put his bishop here but it was about
I don't know 10 moves too late I'm
approximating it's probably fewer than
that but so what is why play now I would
calculate e 6 before blitzing out rookie
2 but in this case you're correct
I'm sure you looked at it all so in this
case though yeah if you tried ecigs I
believe takes on a 4 would be kind of
annoying because now
stop whistling at me because now I've
takes rook than this rook hangs take
sticks you're even material all of a
sudden and if you take back then I take
back on e6 so not not the ideal so
routine and now black has some problems
you've achieved your dream doesn't
happen too often I know it's amazing I'm
sure he felt great about himself he six
is ready you have all your pieces lined
up and blacks position kind of just
falls apart but he's still very precise
he plays riff t2 so what now
Queen d8 was probably the best move but
life is still rough life life is still
not great but this would be a better
move
he played Queen d7 with idea that kind
of discouraged EC's so what does why
play
well let's go back to basics any given
position what are the first moves you
look at
there's a name for those types of moves
temple moves forcing rooms exactly so
what gets calculated first thank you
so what happens at three six
black pretty much has to capture it
right I mean okay black doesn't have to
but if black doesn't capture it it's
definitely your move probably right
because then you can you can trade off
your only potential weakness you weaken
the light squares it just achieves
everything so after pawn takes pawn but
what are whites options Knight g6 Jack
is definitely an option
9066 is definitely an option
anything
appealing to anyone very good
so this is where I think some people go
wrong they give up on variations too
quickly so for example if you calculate
e 6f take c6 and you go well Knight g6
King G it doesn't lead anywhere Knight
takes c6 is not possible and you kind of
give up it makes it so that you don't
consider it and then you have to play an
inferior move but e6 is clearly the move
here and the reason why is because you
have this tactic with 19 c6 so it's
important you make sure that no matter
how good you think your position is or
how bad whatever that you try to not
give up too early because if you miss
Knight takes c6 you're probably not
going to play e6 right and the idea of
course is that if rook takes c6 what
happens Queen f8 check King h7 Queen f5
check in you pick up 2
so instead white black played this move
so
does this move threatened rook takes e6
because it covers that bait square so
let's not allow that
possible but the not only six is a
pretty nice piece wouldn't you say queen
of five looks nicer to me whenever you
have a piece that's this good you
shouldn't want to move it back right you
want to keep it if you can
so Queen f5 I think so nice move not to
mention that black has to be very
careful now because for example a move
like Knight g5 might be a threat or even
Knight takes g7 some move like this
because keep in mind that the Queen's
are attacked the rooks are attacked so
there's going to be tactics galore in a
position like this so black played
rookie seven to guard everything
so now one
this was I think White's maybe only
mistake of the whole game and it's not
even that big of a mistake it's an okay
move but probably not as best
I would say that you have lots of good
like good moves in a position like this
it's not like a position where you have
just one good move but okay I think the
first thing you want to look at is you
know what are the most forcing moves
right Queen FA King h7 you don't quite
have enough right your queen is kind of
in the way you'd like to play another
fake check but your Queens there if
Queen a5 check the King goes back
doesn't quite work out
I don't know when I say a position like
this I want to see if I have attacking
moves Queen g6 yousa okay Queen g6 I
mean I can stop that threat right I
don't know I would look at trying to
just open up the King right whenever I
see a vulnerable King like this I want
to try to open it up so okay after pawn
takes you need to make sure you have
something here but I don't know I like
it this this doesn't seem to work out so
well king g6 I I couldn't find him I
couldn't find anything here it seems
like you've actually done more harm than
good but okay I mean even a move like
Queen g6 looks very tempting you have to
make sure you you know really are
careful because you play a move like
this at the wrong moment it could be
really bad actually yeah this oh yeah
yeah there there are other options too
for example Queen a paycheque yeah I
remember now here and then a move like
rookie four could be nasty
because if rook takes c6 you have Queen
f5 check and now your your your Brooks
ready to slide over so like Knight takes
g5 and rook g4 could be just nasty so I
think the black King is under heavy fire
now but okay I mean it's not easy to
play a move like this he did something
very understandable which is he just
played f4 he wants to solidify that
night on e6 right so black played Queen
back
so what now
I would say he has that he founded our
nice housekeeping move here what the
housekeeping move
yep very nice defend the rook right
defend your f4 pawn just to improve your
position moves like this are central to
good technique I would say you know make
sure you you make you keep your whole
position together you make sure that
there are no and then you check for
tactics because usually Tec good
technique involves lots of tactics Eve
often little tactics that help you get
your way a little bit and you'll see
what I mean later black played King G it
maybe not best but again there just
aren't that many moves so how can white
improve the position now ask yourself
which piece is not quite right there's a
piece of whites which can definitely be
improved between the four pieces White
has which piece is out of place the
queen is not only not doing something
what move does white want to play to
really solidify his position right once
the pawn gets that five blacks just
probably just going to be so depressed
he'll just resign the partner f5 is
really strong right so the key is how do
you put upon an f5 yep
very nice so this is again where Queen
e4 will be an okay move but I think this
one's even better because it makes a
threat on the bishop and you're using
tactics to your advantage this is again
part of good technique is using tactics
to help you usually if you have a great
pieces and a great position upper pond
or not often tactics will just work for
you because your position is better than
your opponents their King is worse their
pieces are worse so tactics are usually
going to favor you use them to your
advantage so queen d3 i think is an
excellent move what happens if rook
takes c6 queen c4 with a pin and if king
here then we finally get to play our
move and black Polly resigns so black
played Bishop back to being light plays
which move but BAM so I mean imagine
this though at the beginning white
started with an extra pawn which wasn't
even that good look at White's extra
pawn now it's that pawn on f5 that I
would call a very very good extra pump
so black played rook do so
again probably several good moves he
chose a centralizing move which I'm
always for even more central right
almost always like the center is just a
great place for a queen if you're ever
not sure put your queen in the center
I'm just telling you
Queen c4 looked fine but then maybe
queen of seven and there's a pin and who
knows queenie 4 is just central ready to
do stuff so black played here and then
resigned after one more move very nice
so why 95 if Queen takes then Queenie a
checker takes rook and note how the
Queen not only wins the rook but it
covers all the checks this Queen cannot
give a single check
actually by the way guys III got very
sloppy here in this position white is
not going to take this rope and now be
precise guys
now black sorry yeah he had no intention
of taking that and after and otherwise
you have to basically trade Queens and
then you take with rook and now there's
a rook e8 check and rook hanging which
means you have to play here probably
right and okay two pawns down with the
worst position against the GM you can
safely resign so that was that um
but you can see how white just slowly
improved his position and then towards
the end you saw how he still had a plan
he wanted to put his pawn on f5 and he
also um you know he had you know he to
use little tactics to help him out to
win the game all right
um whoa all right two two two
so I was going to show
yeah so this game was crazy we could go
over all of it uh yeah but I believe
this was the moment it's okay you still
have to figure out what Y so this
position is white to move so here this
has been just a crazy crazy game
um I mean there's no other way really to
describe it it's just been nuts um and
this is not a position where clear plan
really makes that much sense or whatever
is going on but you still want to have
an idea of how your pieces coordinate
and what the ideas are I would say that
in this particular position white has a
good position but black had a better
idea of where she wanted her pieces and
what her ideas were and because of that
black was able to win this game so what
would you play as white and why
well the problem is white played Bishop
d2 which is just not active enough the
key is you want to take on f4 right
what's the problem if you do it right
away
excuse me
you might you you might want to you
might want to think about this
see that I made it so complicated that
even if you see the answers you're not
going to get it
so first let's check out 93 what is y
plane up and this is where you have to
make sure you look at all your
opponent's possibilities if you slack on
that if you're like ah some move like
this this is where you're going to come
up short
White has an excellent move here
process of elimination if you just move
the Queen and lose your bishop you're
dead
if you don't move the Queen and give up
your queen you're probably also dead we
can safely assume therefore temple moves
always right imagine if you miss that
move have to say with King right because
if you allow Queen takes b5 check you're
just going to get slaughtered tapes
check check check
whoa-oh and let's just say you up some
problems so what do you do instead
correct and now
shall we
yeah this never works out just don't do
it so came back
and now what's the point
very nice back rank mate this is not a
check so you have to calculate carefully
and see details in the position it's the
only way you're going to find this stuff
looking for details so that is why you
play rook a5 first and then take and now
your problems are a lot smaller let's
just say however in the game black white
played here which was too slow black
played Nike three I'll even let you guys
Queen here so now what
so what's why it's problem now after 93
Queen a5 right and the fact that her
Queens out of the game is a big problem
yeah this is by the way just to I was
going to fill you in but I ended up
getting to absorb was making sure you
didn't see her okay five this was a game
it was in the last round between India
and the US in the Women's Olympiad and
this is actually our US Champion nazia
akiza as black she actually didn't have
a great tournament there overall I would
say like she performed below where she
certainly can but this last round win
could have actually won the match for us
and maybe would have had a shot at some
medal unfortunately our board three
ended up losing but this was a really
crucial game and I'm sure both sides are
really quite nervous but yep well you
can give a check first right so notice
how whites I mean it looks very tactical
and concrete and it is you have to be
calculating like crazy a position like
this however notice how blacks play has
a clear purpose right
I'm putting put the note on d3 Queen on
c5 secure the Queen on a5 and then try
to play for direct King side threats it
doesn't seem like much of a plan but it
is because you know you're really just
trying to open up your opponent so fg3
was played
so native to you're gonna have problems
right because you lose be fiber check
and probably most likely not to get too
violent probably it's not going to be
good for you let's put it this way but
look at all blacks pieces they're
perfect which means you probably can't
improve them right what can you improve
what do you need to do to get make
threats here
if you're in doubt pick the one that
doesn't lose
yeah um so yeah black tries to go and
break up the King right because if Black
gets in h4 and takes here it's just
going to be over right it's slow but
it's also I mean White has to do
something pretty fast right because
otherwise they're going to be some real
problems and in this position White has
only one way to stay in the game and
actually maybe even be better but it
requires seeing a couple really
difficult moves
and this is where white fell apart I
mean it's a difficult position but the
key is you have to figure out exactly
you know exactly how to get get in the
game so what was the problem you said
that white has here you pointed it up
well it's White's problem here other
than the fact that the H pawns coming
down and the Queen on a five so Queen to
a three is actually not this move Queen
to a 3 is actually an incredible move so
the idea is that after Knight F to check
rook takes Queen takes White has another
incredible move
not that incredible the problem Bishop
e6 King takes is that I'm threatening
matin one on g2 so you have to mate all
the check and you cannot do it because I
can run to f5
even if I defend e6 there I'm not
convinced you're a threat excellent so
the idea is that now you're threatening
this if takes then this real case and
notice how it's all with tempo right
Queen e7 checks actually very annoying
so black has to stop it and now white
plays rook f1 and then further craziness
temple moves
notice how that's why you put the bishop
on g5 and white actually how black
actually has some problems because it
takes then Queen takes check takes this
guy with check everything falls apart
for blood so again I mean it's very
complicated it takes a while we'd have
to spend like another hour going over
this to cover every line but it's more
about like making sure you spot these
resources right because I mean what my
guess would be neither side had a lot of
time so finding ideas like this is
really difficult but you can still think
in terms of okay I need to fix my queen
my Queens horrible so queen a3 look at
the force in line with Knight F to check
takes takes Bishop g5 again a temple
move looking at the e7 square trying to
create counter play so a process of
elimination can really come in handy and
the problem is that white just probably
didn't have much time but um yeah rook
e1 and now it was pretty simple takes
takes so finish finish white off here
calculate it takes on e6 really a
problem if Bishop takes then King d6 if
we're Bishop here you can always take if
rook moves you the bishop hangs so
always calculate you don't want to have
to play with g6 right so you look it up
to first rook moves now fairness break
up those pawns King T to premiere on she
plays perfectly I would say take so now
the Kings open the question is how to
finish it
what piece do you need to get in the
game to give check man the queen so very
nice my tics
and now this was a nice finishing touch
again look for which piece needs
improvement the Queen perfect Brooke on
f8 perfect and now rook takes h3 rook AJ
check we know five is hard to stop but
you see how quickly that happened right
it went from it looked like white was
doing fine - why was doing okay - white
was lost I'm sure there was time
pressure I mean probably to play a
position ladies in time trouble almost
no one can ever do right
but the key that you know why did black
have more success playing this position
as white than white right she
coordinated her pieces right white I
mean like Bishop d2 clearly at least
said to me that like white didn't have a
sense of urgency as far as how to
improve the pieces like she needed to
force the rook to b8 take on f4 again
it's not so easy to see all the stuff
but the point was that um you know I
didn't really have a plan as far as how
to improve everything that I could see
where as black had a clear plan I want
Queen on c5 blocking the Queen out
Knight on d3 pawn pushing to h4 h5 may
not have even been the best move because
it allowed this crazy Queen a through
Bishop g5 stuff but again finding that
in time crust was really hard will gave
black the advantage was she had a plan
she wanted age five h4 she want to open
up the King she wanted to and then later
she had the plan of improving the Queen
and notice how her plan because she had
a plan and why didn't even though her
position wasn't objectively that great
she was able to win the game by just she
had an idea what she was doing and her
opponent was kind of reacting and not
really knowing what to do this is not a
not a very typical example of a clean
plan like the first game was a perfect
example of okay this is the plan this is
how it goes use some tactics you play
some stuff but basically your plan works
out in this game you know it was just a
mess but black still had an idea of
where she wanted her pieces and what her
plan was and it helped her win the game
and ultimately of course it was a it was
a crucial game in the match
yeah so and what's one of the things
I've noticed about nausea which she
tends to do pretty well which is that
she she definitely is a planner like
she's someone who likes to know exactly
where her pieces are going what her
ideas are and she's good at formulating
something during the game um I'd say a
lot of players don't do that as well
and there are some people who like to
play nonsensical positions or crazy
stuff and she's not bad at that but she
definitely likes to have an idea of
where all her pieces are going and when
she does you can really tell because she
all our moves are kind of harmonious